foreign
[Music]
what you did there and what you built I
mean it's it's really kind of
unprecedented I mean similar I think to
what
you know you know Jim Gandolfini did for
HBO there's an entire empire built there
and it's built you know on on the
shoulders of this character right and
now there's these offshoot shows and
there's you know you versus the
character how much o is there and goes
how much ghost is there though and I get
that and and I am really nobody gets
more than you but like you know and how
you turn that on how you turn that off
how sometimes like you said firefighters
we you got to walk towards the flame
you know sometimes playing apartment and
and you know it's weird saying in front
of the cameras like this what we're
Omari and John because it you know it's
something only a few of us really
understand it does it comes out there's
a huge cost man we we really lose
something and leave something on the
field and when we when we say we're
gonna take something on like that
you know man you you change and
sometimes you don't get it back how do
you feel about where that show landed do
you feel like you were supported do you
feel that that show got the attention uh
across the board that it deserved do you
feel that you were financially
or or just that the business gave you
the flowers you deserve for what you did
for that and again man
um I look at I look at kind of what
Taylor Sheridan's doing right now with
Yellowstone in this that's what y'all
did yes that's what y'all have done and
and and if if ghost doesn't work if
ghost doesn't have that pain that that
glue that adhesive quality where people
say I [__] with this character none of
that exists that's a whole network that
honestly doesn't exist without the work
that you've done if power is this guest
house I didn't walk in with the stature
that you did have preceding your
physicality walking in okay
I absolutely
was preceded with with with conversation
and reputation of being pretty freaking
talented
I was
specifically perhaps
connected at least to the predecessor of
ghost if that is free from Gridiron Gang
having worked with Dwayne Johnson and
exhibit and and the likes of some other
Jay Yorker was the young running back in
that
if you if you include in that shavu my
turn opposite and I know you agree with
me burn a very gifted I think one of the
more gifted but underrated Artisans of
Our Generation as an actor and that
being Wood Harris wood being what he was
as Avon Barksdale on the wire but
equally what he was with me on Next Day
Air with Mike Epps most def and Donald
Faison included I think Lauren London
was in that as well she was
um that might have preceded me walking
in the door oh yeah he smelled he smelt
like ghosts in that character Shabu or
let 50 tell it I think he can play this
based off of me as Curtis I'm speaking
as Curtis having watched him in
characters that were pubescent stages of
a way bigger ghost
but even if Bernthal didn't have in
character in television that
and we talked about this as you
approached Punisher we talked about it
I mean you talked about it rick Roman
wall and you talked about it
maybe as a triumphant we talked about it
some of the fears that you had
I said something one day and I remember
you going yeah but I Punisher is not
that though you're playing a character
that you're able to with obviously the
help of Courtney in her Mighty pen and
Curtis and his ingenuity
and what he's curated in his brain but
perhaps can't put on paper but she put
it on paper and stars having said no I'm
adding this part because I don't think I
told you this burn Stars having said no
to a show so to say yes to power they
they said yes to a show then said no to
the same show they didn't say yes to
just to say nah I'm wrong we're gonna go
with power hmm
they're betting on a dark horse
perhaps literally
let it be white execs Chris all bread
included now Chris albrit is connected
to John Bernthal in some capacity people
would ask why in this interview people
say why how Chris OBET is formerly at
HBO John Bernthal is connected to
Gandolfini rest in peace
via the spin-off if you will
of Jimmy gannofini's lead
Sopranos Jimmy ganofiti is never going
to be somebody that would say that it's
all about him if anything I've heard all
the stories of him feeding all of the
crew left and right I've heard of the
stories him battling drug use I know it
I know that he missed certain days of
work I know that equally burned if I
miss five minutes of work they were on
my ass
Jimmy gandufini rest in peace missed
five days of work at times I'm aware of
it I read difficult men I know and I
know difficult men is more about Mr
chases of the world Courtney Kemps of
the world the curators and creators of
these shows that then ask us to be Tom
Brady's
burn I wasn't necessarily brought in as
touted
as Tom Brady was leaving New England
going to Tampa John Bernthal came in if
you got ghosts you would have come in in
bigger stature than me walking in so
because I didn't come in in bigger
stature that show if you will made me
it didn't make me in my definition
but because it made me to other people's
belief
they can fill away
if they don't feel like they're being
given the credit
and ironically I only give credit where
credit is due I am as good as the
weakest actor this show goes as far as
the weakest crew member
and if 50 doesn't hire me and I've said
50 you had to be hella secure to hire me
you could have been insecure and hired
some guys that are nowhere near my
talent
50 learned that I was aware how gifted I
was burn you and I know how gifted we
are we think that everybody else assumes
that we think we're gifted I've learned
that some people
because of our humility think we don't
know how gifted we are some people feel
more in control when you come off like
you didn't know you had the [__]
Bernthal I could never play one down
let's go back to football
I could never even dress up in the
locker room if I didn't know how gifted
I was
but when we don't come off that way
some people really are taken aback the
day that you come off that way I believe
the day that I came off like I knew how
gifted I was
everything changed what was that not
always for the better how so no longer
was I in control of the faculty of that
which they put me in control of when
they asked me to play quarterback
if you ask me to play quarterback
then you have to allow me to sometimes
call the place yeah
if you ask me to play quarterback not
producer just quarterback I'm not at all
of this notion that I was a producer I
tried to get that credit I wasn't
allowed it right I mean
even that blew the mind of many of me's
yeah
on a show not far over you have people
playing Olivia Pope who are dear friends
of mine on Scandal Kerry Washington's to
be specific blown away that I was never
offered an opportunity to rap yeah
that's crazy I realized burnt off
that our industry includes so many
people if not the majority you're going
to smile they are insecure oh yeah so
they don't really love themselves prior
yeah yeah
I missed that memo yeah you might say
brother how the naivete are you an idiot
oh I was
I was an idiot
so I did the best that I could in an
environment oftentimes burned that as
much as I'm flawed and [__] up and
insane and got some weird idiosyncrasies
I might be the most flawed and most odd
person on set hello you hired me to play
the most odd complex person that's right
but I'm so secure with it and many
people are not secure with their Oddity
and if you're playing the game I know
how to play this Muffler yeah okay
that's what we're gonna do let's rock
and that left a bitter taste in my mouth
which I've had to do a lot of work at
unbittering and deciding this was par
for the course and I can hear Grandpa
rest in peace saying count it all how do
you finish the sentence Bernie Joy
hmm I can't go I can't go at anybody I
gotta say thank you God that's right
thank you for their insecurities that's
right it taught me so much
I thought that you know in season two
summer Hiatus movie
what was that oh that was a movie called
shot caller I thought that in season two
into season three
once you meet at John Bernthal and he's
that level of secure what happens is you
put your guard down Bernie I learned and
Carmi zolotnik told me this formerly
number two in command at HBO right next
to Chris albrit the story to HBO
there is nothing like HBO all these
streaming platforms Netflix included are
all piggybacking HBO let's give credit
where it's due home box office was
different it was groundbreaking I got
that team they then came the Stars but
the character himself was one of the
greatest things to ever play I could
ever play
[Music]
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my Sun Warrior Shake they've
got the active protein but they also
have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones for 15 off I appreciate y'all
foreign